[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen ihnen allen Norbert König ist
auch dabei für den Sport ja guten Abend
großer Festtag heute in Paris
60 Jahre Freundschaft Deutschland und
Frankreich feiern den elisee-vertrag und
loten Gemeinsamkeiten aus auch zum
Ukraine Krieg
Peru im Chaos die Proteste werden immer
heftiger touristen müssen die Inka Stadt
Machu Picchu verlassen
und glanzvoll ins Viertelfinale bei der
Handball WM feiert Deutschland den
fünften Sieg im fünften Spiel
[Musik]
sich nach einem furchtbaren Krieg zu
versöhnen das ist möglich zeigen
Deutschland und Frankreich eine
militärische Auseinandersetzung zwischen
den beiden Nachbarn ist unvorstellbar
geworden zwar gab es zuletzt einige
Spannungen heute aber sollte gefeiert
werden 60 Jahre Freundschaft
am 22 Januar 1963 unterzeichneten der
damalige Bundeskanzler Konrad Adenauer
und Frankreichs Präsident Charle de
Gaulle den elisee-vertrag aus ehemaligen
Kriegsgegnern wurden Verbündete wie das
heute aussieht zeigt
es ist eine Geste mit viel
Interpretationsspielraum wie eng ist die
Freundschaft zwischen Olaf Scholz und
Emanuel macron und wie groß sind die
Spannungen an dem Tag an dem Sie hier
mit möglichst viel würde ihre 60 Jahre
Freundschaft feiern wollen nur mit dem
anderen an unserer Seite als Freund und
engstem Partner als kuble fratanel hat
auch unser eigenes Land eine gute
Zukunft
nachdem es in den letzten Monaten
ordentlich geknirscht hat in der
deutsch-französischen Beziehung etwa
beim Umgang mit der Energiekrise oder
der gemeinsamen Verteidigungspolitik und
dann wurde auch noch der Ministerrat im
Herbst verschoben heute nachgeholt bei
der gemeinsamen Pressekonferenz jetzt
die drängende Frage was ist mit der
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern an die
Ukraine
so wie wir in der Vergangenheit
vorgegangen sind immer eng abgestimmt
mit all unseren Freunden und verbindeten
mündeten die konkrete Lage besprechend
werden wir auch in der Zukunft Vorgehen
bezüglich der panzerlegt habe ich den
Verteidigungsminister gebeten nichts
auszuschließen aber wir müssen das
Kollektiv entscheiden der elisee-vertrag
sollte 1963 den dauerhaften Frieden in
Europa sichern mit dem Krieg in der
Ukraine scheint es wichtiger denn je
dass die Nachbarn Deutschland und
Frankreich zusammenhalten
fragen wir Thomas Walde in Paris noch
mal zu den Kampfpanzern für die Ukraine
wo liegen da die Unterschiede zwischen
Deutschland und Frankreich
also der Auftritt war insofern ja eine
rollenkonform als Emanuel macron da ein
bisschen marikiger aufgetreten ist auch
wenn die Franzosen am Ende dann
vielleicht nicht ganz so viele Waffen im
wirklichen Leben liefern an die Ukraine
aber diese Auftritt entspricht so ein
bisschen dem französischen
Rollenverständnis als ehemaliger Welt
und immer noch Atom macht und der
Präsident ist in diesem Land derjenige
der institutionell die Außenpolitik
bestimmen kann in Deutschland ist es ja
ein bisschen anders man liefert de facto
sehr viele Waffen in die Ukraine mehr
als die Franzosen will dabei aber nie
als jemand Auftreten der besonders
markig ist oder gar die anderen antreibt
das hat ja auch damit zu tun dass das in
Deutschland eben nicht ein Präsident ist
der darüber entscheidet sondern am Ende
die Bundeswehr eine Parlamentsarmee ist
eine solche intensive Diskussion wie in
Deutschland um diese Panzerlieferungen
gibt es deswegen auch in Frankreich in
dieser Form nicht noch ganz kurz ihr
Fazit von heute wurden die Spannungen
der letzten Monate ausgeräumt
also dieser Tag war so gestaltet von der
Tagesordnung bis zur Tonalität dass
beide Seiten hier Gemeinsamkeiten
demonstrieren wollten feiern wollten
dass man an den Bogen schlagen wollte
von der Geschichte über die gemeinsame
historische Verantwortung zur
deutsch-französischen Freundschaft hin
zu einem Führungsanspruch in Europa
alles was der stören konnte hat man
außen vorgelassen dieses sollte ein Tag
sein der Besinnung nach innen der
Rückversicherung nach innen und einem
gemeinsamen Formulieren eines Anspruches
nach außen die Einschätzung unseres
Frankreich Korrespondenten vielen Dank
Thomas Walde live aus Paris
60 Jahre deutsch-französische
Freundschaft wie und warum der
elisee-vertrag zustande kam und was man
sich darin vorgenommen hatte das gibt es
zusammengefasst in der ZDF heute App
wo uns Ministerpräsident moraviewski
nennt das deutsche zögern bei der
Leopard 2 Lieferung inakzeptabel falls
die Bundesregierung dabei bleibe werde
Polen eine kleine Koalition aus Ländern
bilden und die Ukraine aus eigenen
Beständen mit modernen Panzern versorgen
allerdings braucht Polen die Zustimmung
Deutschlands wenn es Panzer aus
deutscher Produktion weitergeben will
auch wegen des russischen angriffskriegs
in der Ukraine überdenkt die SPD ihre
Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik morgen
berät das Präsidium über ein 21 Seiten
langes Positionspapier darin wird
Deutschland eine Führungsrolle in Europa
zugewiesen zudem will sich die SPD
künftig explizit zum 2% Ziel der NATO
bekennen
in die USA in Kalifornien hat ein Mann
zehn Menschen in einem Tanzlokal
erschossen und weitere 10 zum Teil
schwer verletzt zu den Schüssen kam es
während der Feierlichkeiten zum
chinesischen Neujahrsfest in Monterey
Park einem Vorort von Los Angeles der
mutmaßliche Täter ist auf der Flucht des
Motiv unklar in Monterey Park leben
viele Menschen asiatische Herkunft
Israels Regierungschef Netanjahu hat
seinen Innenminister dery entlassen
nachdem das Oberste Gericht den Chef der
Ultra ultra-orthodoxen schaspartei als
ungeeignet erklärt hatte wegen seiner
Vorstrafen
Netanjahu bedauerte die Entscheidung der
Ries Ernennung war eine Forderung der
ultra-orthodoxen bei den
Koalitionsverhandlungen ob seine
Entlassung nun zum Bruch der Regierung
führt ist noch unklar
seit Wochen gibt es in Peru blutige
Proteste gegen die Regierung tausende
Anhänger des abgesetzten Präsidenten
castigo liefern sich immer wieder
Straßenschlachten mit der Polizei das
Land in Südamerika hat knapp 34
Millionen Einwohner und ist mehr als
drei Mal so groß wie Deutschland bis zum
Jahr 2000 wurde es autoritär regiert
seitdem gab es zehn verschiedene
Präsidenten nun beeinträchtigen die
Unruhen auch immer mehr den Tourismus
hoch oben auf einem Berggipfel das
inkajuwel Machu Picchu doch am Fuße des
Weltkulturerbes 400 Touristen die
weggebracht werden müssen Machu Picchu
geschlossen zum Schutz der Besucher denn
die Proteste gegen die Regierung sind
inzwischen landesweit heftig und blutig
am Wochenende stürmen Sicherheitskräfte
die besetzte markus-universität in der
Hauptstadt Lima
die Polizei ist mit Gewalt eingedrungen
hat alle Demonstranten in der Uni
verhaftet sie hat Tränengas eingesetzt
und hat Menschen angegriffen
mehr als 200 werden festgenommen das
sind keine Terroristen rufen Sie auf der
Demo kurz danach
seit Wochen immer wieder wütende
Proteste Straßenschlachten vor ein paar
Tagen im Zentrum von Lima ein
historisches Gebäude in Flammen die Lage
außer Kontrolle die Demos sie begannen
im Dezember nach der Festnahme des
damaligen Präsidenten Pedro castigo er
hatte versucht das Parlament aufzulösen
seine Stellvertreterin Diener bouleate
übernimmt die Macht als erste Frau in
Peru sie solle zurücktreten fordern die
Demonstranten viele aus dem armen Süden
und Castillo linke Hoffnungsträger
freigelassen werden trotz
Korruptionsvorwürfen die Menschen aus
den ländlichen und indigenen Regionen
setzten auf ihn jetzt Notstand in Teilen
von Peru über 50 Tote viele Festnahmen
das Anden Land versinkt im Chaos
und jetzt bist du dran Norbert mit
Wintersport genau dem Blick zum Biathlon
Weltcup in Antholz dort haben die
deutschen Männer beim Staffelsieg der
dominierenden Norweger Platz 3 erreicht
das gleiche gelingt auch dem Frauenteam
riesenjubel bei Schlussläuferin Hanna
kebinger im letzten Staffelrennen vor
den Weltmeisterschaften erkämpft sich
das deutsche Damen Quartett einen
ausgezeichneten dritten Rang vor
ausverkauftem Haus in Antholz und der
Strich Vanessa Vogt als Startläuferin
die medaillenambitionen der deutschen
genauso wie Sophia Schneider die an
Position 2 ins Rennen geht auch ohne die
nominelle Nummer eins im Team Denise
Herrmann Wick dafür mit Janina hätte ich
weiß und Hanna Kiebinger im zweiten Teil
überzeugten die deutschen Damen hinter
Frankreich und Schweden
Olympiasiegerin Laura Nolte ist jetzt
doppel-europameisterin nach dem Titel im
monobob Gestern gewinnt sie mit Nele
shooten auch die zweier EM in Altenberg
bei den Männern holt Francesco Friedrich
mit seinem Team Silber im Viererbob
hinter dem Briten red Haul
Torfestival in Dortmund der BVB besiegt
im Ersten Bundesliga Sonntagsspiel den
FC Augsburg mit 4 zu 3 und verdrängt
Wolfsburg wieder von Platz 6
die deutschen Handball-Nationalspieler
surfen weiter auf der Erfolgswelle 5
Sieg im fünften Spiel mit dem 33 zu 26
gegen die Niederlande bei der
Weltmeisterschaft gelingt vorzeitig die
Qualifikation für das Viertelfinale
sogar beim Krafttraining noch ein
Lächeln im Gesicht super gut also
souverän machen ich glaube das haben wir
selbst auch nicht erwartet die Anfang
Niederländer können schnell nicht mehr
mithalten der Mann des Spiels zeichnet
sich schon in der ersten Hälfte ab
Torhüter Andreas Wolf in Weltklasse Form
den Viertelfinale Einzug klar gemacht
Frankreich und Spanien die potenziellen
Gegner ich würde lieber gegen Spanien
spielen wenn es dann aber am Ende
Frankreich wird dann schlagen wir die
auch dann geht es morgen aber im letzten
Hauptrundenspiel gegen Norwegen
aber egal wer es wird wir sehen uns
Mittwoch im ZDF juhu Dankeschön Norbert
fehlt noch das Wetter morgen gibt es
viele Wolken und nur wenig Sonne es
bleibt aber trocken bei einem im Süden
lebhaften Nordostwind werden minus zwei
bis plus 5 Grad erreicht das heute
journal um viertel vor zehn mit
marientas Slomka das gesamte 19 Uhr Team
sagt tschüss wünscht Ihnen einen guten
Start in die neue Woche und empfiehlt
jetzt Theo Colt und Berlin direkt